[Music]
from the Disney of gaming and the EA of
film comes a swashbuckling romp about a
buff dude a smaller quippy guy and a
sexy lady with an accent to hunt down a
mythical Treasure Red notice I I mean
Jungle Cruise no wait I mean Uncharted
uh since when did bad versions of the
Mummy become its own genre the Uncharted
games make you feel like you're playing
an action movie now the big screen
adaptation has arrived and you'll feel
like you're watching someone else play
Uncharted while you fall asleep on their
couch that plucks a few cool moments
from the games
and scrambles everything else into a
bland cinematic paste but hey everyone
loves an Unfaithful game adaptation
right
right
no and why did this one get a pass are
you that horny for Spider-Man do better
Humanity Tom Holland is Peter Parker
with a fake ID after growing roughly
five years from his childhood flashback
Nate's become one of those bartenders
who thinks of themselves as more of a
mixologist an agroni first made in 1919
for count Camilo Negroni when he swapped
the soda water in his usual drink the
Americano virgin in between shaking
appletinis he's also become a
self-taught history scholar and parkour
expert who definitely knows how to shoot
a gun
oops I was thinking of the games again
silly me no this version just knows how
to chew some gum
we should actually put the gun in the
martini he's not a bad idea you know
it's one thing to cast a younger Nathan
for a prequel but do they really have to
treat him like a buff little toddler the
whole time still working on the tie I
just can't figure out the length I made
you a drink Shirley Temple it's
hilarious puberty's right around the
corner kids you can grow your own
when you put Boston and a crucifix in
your script you summon Mark Wahlberg and
when Marky Mark remarks on Nate's mark
it was very Mark he'll deny Marky Mark's
Mark remarks I'm not a morph in some bar
but when Marky Mark remarks on your mark
mark my words your Marky Mark's next
Mark watch them form a mini me even mini
or me relationship there's only like one
inch taller than me as this charming
one-dimensional actor shows Tom Holland
his acting future you think that I know
something yeah
do you did you really just ask me that
Bravo gentlemen powerful stuff and when
they throw a woman into the mix with all
the depth and backstory of a cave troll
one day I found a bronze statue covered
in gems buried under a bridge it'll kick
off a Non-Stop three-way of double
crosses Sally where are you going you
can't leave me you let it take the cross
you'll let her take a pause give it to
me you're kidding right well we I'm
sorry Nate yeah I might let her steal
the wrong coordinates in a quick field
Face-Off over actual crosses give me a
cross I'm not giving you my cross why
would I do that you don't need them both
give me the cross if you haven't said
please throw your key down did you think
you're gonna double cross me you want
the stupid here you want the gold so
give me the key yeah it goes on like
this for like 90 minutes trust me we're
gonna have to figure out a way to trust
each other she's not to be trusted the
minute you start to trust someone you
lose you can trust me trust me oh you
don't trust me well you don't trust me I
don't trust anybody it's 5 billion in
Gold just split it three ways morons
what are you trying to do by Twitter
strap in for a globetrotting adventure
but like the kind where you stay in
hostels to cut costs as Nate and Sully
travel from the kitty gut wet bar in
Manhattan to Spain's most ancient Papa
John's I'm like literally in a Papa
John's right now to a cave with not one
but two old boats inside so good Goonies
all stitched together by a thin paste of
banter parkour and Blues Clues level
puzzles in a film that doesn't even try
to justify why two Boston jabronis can
steal another country's gold for
themselves what he's some kind of
Professor or something just shut up and
fill your cargo pants okay and while
you're at it say hello to your brothers
hey that's my line lady so fly through
an adventure so average Netflix is using
it to train their AI that writes their
movies that's not so much a prequel of
Uncharted as it is a Frankenstein's
monster of Uncharted 4. a bad photocopy
of Indiana Jones nuns why is it always
gotta be nice when did you decide to
become Indiana Jones and the soft launch
of the PlayStation Cinematic Universe
pass but how much cooler would it have
been if they crossed it over with I
don't know God of War Saints Row and
Assassin's Creed what the hell happened
to YouTube that doesn't count
starring
Peter parkour
oh my God
parkour wahlburglaries I'm puss in suits
goons Never Say Die Gray's archeology
Noah North on vacation by himself in the
Philippines hmm Uncharted fans when they
watch this movie so Drake Drake
and oh crap remastered holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
Tom Raider
wait a minute Naughty Dog the company
exists in this world what games do they
make
the more I understand Humanity the more
I love my dog